the French Alps around Shimoni at an
elevation of some 2,600 meters Austrian
free skier Eva volkner sets out on the
second stage of the freeride world tour
jumping cliffs and rocks that are meters
high it's great being on the mountain
the snow is fantastic so it's lots of
fun thirty-six-year-old Ava vagner is a
star among free riders skiers who go off
piste into the backcountry she's already
chalked up several victories in past
freeride world tours in 2015 she became
world champion this sport is about far
more than speed this is me I Jesus it's
more about reading the mountain knowing
where the cliffs are that I'm going to
jump the route that I've plotted always
many emails or the other way around
about finding a route I look at the
slope from the other side and from above
from above it looks completely different
from below it's just rocks but from
above it's a little roll over you have
to find the exact drop in
held annually since 2008 the freeride
world tour is the world's most demanding
free riding competition it's held in
five stages in five countries only the
start and finish lines are set the route
in between is plotted by each athlete
referees award points for every rung if
a partner is once again the woman's
favorite about the jewel eta of you this
year once again ava has a really good
chance she's talented she hardly ever
wipes out she's very fast and
technically quite strong she can also
jump high she's got everything it takes
to win again this year Eva was born in
1979 just south of Salzburg she started
learning to ski at the age of three soon
she was taking part in international
races in 1995 she entered the europa cup
for austria in 2010 she switched to free
riding even after several Falls and
injuries she hasn't given up her
ambition keeps her going yes I take the
sport very seriously more so than many
others perhaps opinion so mom I do an
extreme amount of training in summer and
even in winter I spent five or six days
a week at our Olympic Center in Salzburg
training for four to five hours a day
which is very tough sometimes it can get
monotonous in the weight room Eva
Faulkner is one of the very few women
who can make a living from free riding
though the fees women command are not
high men of the same skill level can
earn ten times as much from sponsors and
advertising
scada bonefish talk for us women there's
a very strong emphasis on movie parts
not just for the world tour but for
skiing films ones human America the
biggest American production companies
are 95% men and five percent women so we
women have to work very hard at this
show Thea what Robert and fitted her
strategy is straight up athletic
achievements which she demonstrated most
clearly in 2015 after two years off to
let a torn ligament heal she easily won
the freeride world tour for women skiers
ah anything I do I wasn't even expecting
it my goal was to make the top five but
when i won that's when the tears started
Thor was raining it clean in focus Eva
vogner a woman with drive and discipline
who's taken the lead in the male domain
of extreme sports